china's aggressive pandemic lockdowns
haven't just imprisoned many residents
of the world's most populous country in
their homes they've also dramatically
slowed commerce across the global supply
chain we haven't really seen the true
impacts of that disruption yet so i
think it's one of the best bellwethers
right now for what's going on and where
we're headed globally in terms of a
potential economic recession
although china's ports are still working
only about 20 percent of the trucking
capacity in the economic powerhouse of
shanghai is operating that's meant raw
materials and components for finished
products are not getting to the ports
for export to the us and elsewhere the
entire supply chain has been
constrained and
limited so there's
very
uh
there's limited movement at every stage
of the supply chain uh which
is relatively unprecedented to have kind
of this full stop of movement
in small town northwest arkansas
hundreds of transportation experts have
gathered to speed up the pace of trade
at a conference on the future of the
supply chain the people here at this
conference know there's nothing they can
do about lockdowns in china or fuel
shortages due to the war in ukraine they
are here to decide how they can respond
to it and minimize the damage
some chinese factories are expected to
shut down when their current supplies
run out experts predict that will
contribute to a trucking crisis in the
u.s shippers expect overall demand to
fall by 23 percent from last year
amazon launched its freight subsidiary
in 2020 just as the pandemic hit and
after two rough years the company's
small business leader says the future
remains just as uncertain
john maynard keynes
used to say that the only true future is
that all
all of us are going to end up dead so if
you're asking me about
forecasting
i cannot give you the the answer i don't
have the crystal ball with lockdowns in
china expected to continue through june
truckers are bracing for a rough summer
and high prices due to inflation are
expected to quickly sour the economic
engine of the u.s the consumer later
this year john hendren al jazeera rogers
arkansas